they're they're very amazing exits for
companies where if you sell a company
for a hundred million bucks and you walk
with founder owns 40 percent or an angel
it's five percent right
yeah no money but it's very easy for a
VC who's already got fifty million
dollars in the bank to be like after
that let's go for it man yeah let's push
for the binaries of the fences yeah well
push for the binary outcome and the
binary outcome means to a lay person
either a billion dollars or zero dollars
right it's one of the other right yeah
they want the grand slam just when you
think about PCs they've all got
portfolio theory they've all got a lot
of a lot of irons in the fire right and
so it's really easy to push an
individual entrepreneur to go for it go
for it go for it Wayne but it's because
if that thing just the bed it doesn't
matter they've got a whole pile of other
things that might work out for them yes
they're they have a mutual fund and the
entrepreneur has picked one stock yeah
exactly and so so I think sometimes it
gets a little disingenuous and the
political infighting exerting so I've
got companies that are well into their
season DS where it's it's ugly like the
boardroom isn't fun you know there's you
know early investors fighting with later
investors fighting with founders
fighting with new managerial CEOs like a
kid sees get away with this nonsense now
because it feels like entrepreneurs and
founders are getting so empowered that
your reputation matters so you know if
you piss off and have Williams now or a
Travis kalmyk you're not going to get
that opportunity when they do the next
company and people remember right
because founders are maniacal people
being one I can say that and that if you
were to just in any way cross them
they'll write you off the list forever
and they're gonna tell everybody they
associated with hey that VC persona
non-grata not a good idea
so our VC behavior gotten better in the
last decade or worse it's gotten better
but it's still pretty ugly and here's
the thing what you just said like if if
you had bet me money ten years ago about
the state of politics today I would have
been like well of course like the
internet will we'll take all the data
politics will have a much more
fact-based political discourse like the
truth will float to the top right sure
why we can point to sites that will be
you know unbiased yeah that's like yeah
we'll tell
exactly what the truth is I know you can
vote for and what happened instead like
there's a more convoluted like just the
is metastasized I mean it's just amazing
how many lives there are out there yeah
and so I think the funny thing is as
much as I believe that VC behavior has
generally improved it's that there's the
cult of personality around the VC that
has that has evolved as well and so the
VCS have their own voice and can put
their own spin on it and tell their own
story and ultimately they have results
that can speak for themselves and so if
you screw over Evan Williams Ivan
Williams is certainly gonna cancel other
entrepreneurs hey don't take money from
this guy right but if you're my
guarantee you could be like writing up
or mg or whoever it is high-profile
person make it you say like here's my
side of the story yeah or that investor
though they they still get the Twitter
logo on their site they have a bunch of
other companies they've got a great
return so it does look like they've got
the Midas touch and they're like maybe
I'll suck it up to work with so-and-so
up there yeah so so I'm not sure maybe
the reputation yeah I'm not sure it's
still yeah it's to play out I mean we
and the halcyon analysis we would think
that all this stuff would converge on us
all getting better and also all getting
along and the transparency would win I'm
not sure it happens because I see I see
investors doing really awful still and
they still get rewarded by getting to
invest in great companies they do and I
think a lot of that is like founders you
know believe that the brand of the
investor helps the visibility of their
company there's a cycle I mean you
they're willing to make some trade-offs
yeah